I care about climate justice and the
Living Planet we think you are so
inspirational Greta Sundberg it's pretty
amazing how you have become the face of
the climate movement and you're only 16
we love the way you take on adults and
challenge them to be better you have
shown us that we don't have to wait
until we're grown up to save the world
there's no better time to acts than now
right Greta Greta tunberg isn't the only
awesome girl who is changing the world
we've got ten of the most influential
teenagers of the decade lined up for you
they're totally going to rule the world
one day smart funny interesting
beautiful adventurous Maddie Ziegler
Maddie Ziegler has come a long way since
Stine on Dance Moms the 17 year old star
is proven to be one awesome person not
only is she a successful and talented
dancer and actress but she's also really
kind she has worked with the homeless a
lot she supported the birthday male
project which sends birthday cards to
kids and shelters she also partnered
with dancers against cancer this
organization provides support to dancers
who have been affected by cancer maddie
is passionate about these issues and we
are super impressed Rowan Blanchard you
probably know her as Riley Matthews from
Girl Meets World
the Rowan Blanchard is a lot more than
just an actress this 17 year old girl is
all about social justice Rowan is
incredibly outspoken about issues such
as gun violence human rights and
feminism she has even addressed the
United Nations at their Women's
Conference she uses her voice and her
platform to talk openly about issues
that she believes in Marci Martin
Hollywood is filled with big-name
executive producers buzz Marci Martin is
the youngest of them all
she is just 15 years old and she is
already an executive producer of a major
movie Marci has been acting since she
was four but her real big break came
with the show blackish but then she had
another idea
she loved the 1980s movie big so much
that she decided to make a movie called
little I wanted to create something that
no one has
it's all about a businesswoman who
becomes 13 again Marcy I wanted to see
this movie with the cast of black women
she is committed to diversity and
representation we know we'll see way
more awesome movies from this young
executive Bona al Abed Bona al-abaad is
just ten years old but she is one of the
most active voices about the wars in
Syria she and her mother began tweeting
about the airstrikes in their last few
days in Aleppo she made people realize
that there are real people suffering
there people don't usually see more than
what the news tells them but vanish
showed us exactly how war affects
children like her she continues to tweet
about issues and his rubbing shoulders
with other activists Jojo sua we've got
another Dance Moms alum on this list
Jojo with the bow bow has built a
business empire she's just 16 and owns
one of the most successful businesses
out there she has used her musical and
dancing talents to build an iconic brand
her merch includes everything from
sparkly clothes to fruit snacks her
faces inside stores like Walmart and
Target and he does it all with a huge
grin on her face she is super business
savvy
Naomi Walter Naomi Walter might be one
of the most influential twelve-year-olds
of all time when she was just 11 she
began using her First Amendment right to
protest she led a walkout at her school
to protest to gun violence she was asked
to speak at the national march for our
lives and she is giving a voice to
African American women who have lost
their lives to gun violence she says she
is speaking up for the girls who don't
make the evening news but are still lost
to gun violence
Sadie sink you probably recognize
Sadie's sink from stranger things but
did you know that she is a big advocate
for animal rights and veganism Sadie is
only 17 and she is already making waves
she models for brands created by vegan
designers she tries to be a chill
advocates and not too pushy but she
openly talks about the way animals are
treated and how veganism can help save
the planet
she is definitely using her fame for
causes as she cares about Marley Diaz
Marley Diaz is just 14 and she has been
promoting diversity in literature
since 2015 she told her mom she was
tired of every book being about white
boys and dogs so she started the 1,000
black girl books campaign the goal was
to collect and donate 1000 books with
black girl main characters the campaign
exploded she works alongside
policymakers on how to increase
diversity in literature this young woman
is a published author herself
Greta thun burg Greta Thumb burg is
everywhere these days this 16 year old
Swedish girl is one of the leading
activists for climate change policies
she built a zero emissions boat to come
to America as a statement about
renewable energy she started a school
strike she speaks to government agencies
like the UN you have stolen my dreams my
childhood with your empty words and
tells them that they are failing her
generation by refusing to give climate
change the attention it deserves
Kayode ended when pay attended was just
11 years old she was being forced into a
child marriage now she fights to keep
other girls from having to get married
as children hey-yah managed to put an
end to child marriage in her village and
india and she has succeeded in ending it
in several other places too she just
became the first Indian woman to win the
changemaker award by the Gates
Foundation which of these girls do you
think is the most inspiring and why let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching be sure to subscribe to the
things and give this video a big thumbs
up we'll see you next time
[Music]